- Hallo, Papa!
- Ah! Hallo, Lisa!
Guten Tag, Jürgen Brunner
mein Name. Sie sind Nico?
- Ja. Ich heiße Nicolás González.
- Herr González, freut mich sehr.
Setzen Sie sich doch bitte.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Wie ist Ihr Geburtsdatum?
Ich meine:
Wann haben Sie Geburtstag?
Geburtstag?
- Geburtstag.
Adresse?
- Wir nehmen meine Adresse.
Ich wohne in der Wagnergasse 136.
- Ihre Passnummer!
Passnummer.
- Mein Pass ist weg.
- Oh, das ist nicht gut.
- Das ist Yara.
- Und wer ist Yara?
- My aunt.
- Seine Tante!
- Yara ist Ihre Tante.
- Ja, meine Tante.
- Wo wohnt Yara?
Haben Sie eine Adresse?
Ist Yara informiert,
dass Sie hier sind?
- Does Yara know you are here?
Is she waiting for you?
- Seine Tante weiß nicht,
warum er hier ist?
- Nein.
- Warum ist er denn hier in Deutschland?
- Ich weiß es nicht.
Aber ich werde es rausfinden.
- Ich helfe Nico.
- Danke, Papa.
- Gerne.
Wir telefonieren!
Hab viel Spaß heute Abend bei der Party.
- Komm!
- Party?